[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de la
françafrique et de ce qu'il en reste
alors la france en afrique une vieille
histoire avec ses heures et ses malheurs
on pense aux indépendances à
l'émancipation et au développement on
pense aussi aux nombreux coups d'état à
une violence quasi endémique au génocide
rwandais et dernière péripétie en date
le départ programmé de la force barkan
du mali avec 1 re développement au niger
et en côte d'ivoire la france en afrique
c'est aussi des africains en france qui
constitue une diaspora importante dans
les villes et à leur périphérie mais la
france en afrique c'est cette
françafrique qui dit tout et rien d'une
relation spéciale et que certains
associent à du paternalisme pour le
meilleur et pour le pire à une
corruption systémique au regard d'une
afrique qui peine à rentrer dans le
développement socio-économique et dans
l'affirmation régaliennes des états
notre peau va se concentrer sur
l'afrique francophone mais le continent
africain et d'une complexité sans
frontières que nous allons aborder avec
mes invités que je vous présente didier
castres vous êtes général d'armée et
vous êtes spécialiste des opérations
hubert coudurier vous êtes journaliste
et directeur du télégramme
antoine blazer vous êtes journaliste et
depuis des décennies vous consacrer
beaucoup de temps à l'afrique et marc
antoine pérouse de montclos
vous êtes politologue ali r d
[Musique]
alors pourquoi ce dédain ce mépris pour
cette françafrique
au fond qu'est ce qu'on lui reproche
antoine glaser en fait on lui reproche
la françafrique c'est quand même on ne
comprend pas la françafrique si on ne
comprend pas que c'est une période
historique qui va des indépendances
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre froide et
c'est vrai que la france ait trouvé dans
cette région dans une situation disons
de quasi monopole
ça veut dire c'était un système intégré
politique avec un certain nombre de
chefs d'état qui avaient été les jeunes
ne savent pas mais comme houphouët
boigny où léopold sédar senghor
président du sénégal cavité ans des
gouvernements français avant les
indépendances vous aviez un certain
nombre de militaires comme le celui qui
viennent une général eyadéma au togo où
jean bédel bokassa en centrafrique qui
avaient été eux-mêmes dans l'armée
française aux stations intégrées
politique militaire financier économique
et aux non c'est une grande politique
parce que au nom de la lutte contre
l'union soviétique
finalement l'ensemble des mêmes des
alliés de la france lui laisser gérer le
pétrole la france s'est fait virer
l'algérie en 62 donc les le pétrole
l'uranium du golfe de guinée et cetera
lui laisser gérer c'est un système
intégré mais encore une fois on ne
comprend pas la françafrique si on voit
par là on la met pas dans une période
historique particulière qui fait que la
france était dominante mais hadji pas
son corps défendant parce que ça
l'arrangeait mais il y avait une grande
politique pour les entreprises
françaises contre les marchés à 55 on va
rentrer dans le détail mais marc antoine
ou de montclos vous confirmer que c'est
cette proximité entre la france et
l'afrique qui a créé finalement une
difficulté d'autonomie une proximité
voire collusion 1 puisque le mot
françafrique est aujourd'hui très
péjoratif il renvoie à l'idée
deux caisses noires de voir aussi
détournements de fonds deux
d'arrangement à huis clos entre
président français présidents africains
y compris pour le vote de certaines
résolutions nations unies etc mais
initialement quand le mot était employé
dit on pour la première fois par félix
houphouët boigny en côte d'ivoire
c'était plutôt un mot qui avait une
connotation positive qui soulignait
l'ancienneté de relations culturelles
entre l'empiré colonial et puis et puis
la france mais ensuite j'ai eu vraiment
une dérive qui a marqué je suis tout à
fait d'accord sur la rupture de la fin
de la guerre froide qui ont finalement à
perdurer un peu jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui comme ce qu'il faut éviter
en fait l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de
générer la relation entre la france et
l'afrique en sortant de la françafrique
qui aujourd'hui un peu l'épouvantail
contre lequel on doit se repenser la
relation entre entre la france et ses
anciennes colonies puisqu'en fait ton
temps est-ce que ça vous dit hubert
coudurier le mot françafrique tous
immédiatement un peu de mépris il
toujours le tout le talent français pour
l'auto-flagellation je vais prendre
trois exemples récents c'est le
président macron qui tient un sommet je
crois à montpellier où il
invite convoque non pas des chefs d'état
mais des représentants de la société
civile des ong et c'est une grande
rupture par rapport à tous ces sommets
franco-africains du passé et
volonté de dépassement de cette
françafrique qui est d'ailleurs plus ou
moins bien reçus parce que sur le
terrain et on le voit à l'aune du repli
ou du redéploiement de l'opération
barkan on voit les sentiments anti
français qui se sont développées au
terme d'une présence peut être trop
longue d'une occupation militaire qui a
donné des résultats
brillants au départ et à la fin beaucoup
moins concluant comme tout d occupation
qui dure et un troisième exemple que je
trouve assez parlant c'est la vente par
vincent bolloré de son groupe développée
en afrique depuis maintenant trois
décennies
sa vente à msc le croisiériste le
italien
dont on ne sait pas d'ailleurs s'il a
fait l'objet d'un deal avec l'elysée
puisque décrit colère le secrétaire
général est lié à la famille à ponte
mais en tout cas qui marque à une forme
de désengagement du milieu des affaires
après le désengagement militaire dont
nous venons de parler pendant leur
entrée la taille d'un
retrait de la france et des critiques
dont on pourra se demander s'ils ne sont
pas parfois un peu exagéré tout avait
alors on va rentrer dans le détail mais
didier castres deux choses auront été
abordés d'un côté la françafrique vous
dirai ce que ça évoque pour vous est-ce
qu'il ya quelque chose de malicieux là
dedans et la deuxième chose qui vient
d'être abordée par hubert coudurier
est-ce que vous comment vous jugez jeu
c'est un peu un militaire ne juge pas le
politique mais s'appuyer sur les jeunes
générations
s'appuyer sur la société civile est ce
que c'est une manière habile de
contourner les problèmes
sur la question de la françafrique mon
sentiment c'est que la françafrique
c'est un concept fourre tout dans lequel
on met énormément de choses ça veut pas
dire pour autant qu'on peut nier ce qui
s'est passé à l'époque foccart de
vouloir assurer le contrôle de nos
anciennes colonies et ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut nier également toutes
les affaires financières quand tu avoir
lieu des deux côtés de la méditerranée
mais aujourd'hui qu'est ce que c'est que
la françafrique si la françafrique c'est
une politique d' influence de la france
est ce que est ce qu'il est obscène de
dire qu'on a une politique d' influence
en afrique moi je pose cette question
ensuite la nature des relations qu'ils
contribuent est une deuxième chose le
deuxième point le deuxième point que
vous évoquiez c'était sur le fait
d'aborder une politique africaine à
travers les jeunes générations la
société civile en pensant que ça
servirait d'aiguillon pour faire
redémarrer de nouvelles relations franco
le seul fait le seul commentaire c'est
pour moi le commentaire que je fais sur
cette volonté de passer directement par
la jeunesse c'est c'est la façon de dire
que les gouvernements africains sont pas
représentatives de leur pays pour moi
c'est ce que ça veut dire sinon on
passerait par les institutions
régaliennes et nationales de ces pays
antoine glaser c'est astucieux de passer
par la société civile et astucieux
d'abord accessible par rapport à cette
défiance vis à vis des esgaulx
gouvernements africains mais quand vous
êtes président de la république
française c'est là où il ya le piège
african macron parce qu'il va bien les
sociétés civiles il va vers les
diasporas qui sont les français
d'origine africaine mais en tant que
président un public française avec sa
diplomatie d'influencé
quand vous avez un chef d'état comme le
président ben ali bongo ben il faut bien
recevoir le président gabonais même si
les opposants gabonais sont pas contents
parce que le gabon siège au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies depuis mois
de janvier et quand vous avez ce qui est
quand même l'armée le tchad qui est
tellement important pour pour la france
qui est vraiment de l'armée l'armée
française en afrique depuis 1900 quand
vous avez un moment donné la mort
d'idriss deby il ya un état de
sidération à paris en dix ans et
finalement vous avez le président
merling qui se retrouvent qui se
retrouve en première ligne en train à
l'impression d'adouber le fils
une précision une précision est ce que
les sociétés civiles et les jeunes
générations aux deux l'influencent en
afrique oui à ayant beaucoup d'influx
ans mais ce n'est pas au président de la
république française de les organiser
pour les gérer c'est ça le problème
c'est là où il ya le piège vous en
cuisine et elle sait
où et les diasporas africaines ont
beaucoup d'influencé notamment
financières leurs envois de fonds vers
l'afrique rina mais on parle des
sociétés civiles sur place à vous parler
de société civile sur l'afrique là
l'idée était aussi de
d'instrumentaliser les migrants
africains en france alors sur les
sociétés sinon voudrais aborder des deux
les deux volets ouais mais ça c'est pas
nouveau c'est pas la paire et de macron
ça fait depuis la fin de la guerre
froide qui effectivement avec le
consensus de washington comme on
l'appelait l'idée de contourner des
états autoritaires et corrompus en
utilisant les ressorts de la société
dite civile qui est aussi monsieur le
disais tout à l'heure sur la
françafrique la société civile c'est un
concept complètement gloubiboulga remet
un peu tout dedans moi je sais pas très
bien comment définir la société civile
souvent ça passe par des ong des ong
locales ou internationales
mais je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'illusions dans ce domaine parce que
d'abord on pourra jamais contourner le
fait qu' il y aura toujours des
relations bilatérales d'état à état avec
des présidents africains ça c'est
absolument arriver sur place et d'autre
part il ya beaucoup de je crois d'espoir
pas toujours réalistes sur justement la
capacité de ce gloubiboulga qu'on
appelle la société civile ou les ong
locales pour effectivement être des
contre-pouvoirs efficace intègre et non
corrompu parce qu'en réalité c'est ce
que c'était civils sont aussi un calque
des états en place donc si les états
sont autoritaires et corrompus vous
allez retrouver des éléments
d'autoritarisme et de corruption dans
cette société dite civile donc faut pas
avoir une vision manichéenne en disant
il ya les bons d'un côté c'est la
société civile qu'on a beaucoup de mal à
définir et puis d'autre part les
méchants qui seraient les institutions
d'état les présidents les fonctionnaires
etc alors entrant concrètement dans
cette françafrique hubert coudurier
parmi les outils il ya d'un côté le
franc cfa et il ya également
le côté linguistique et culturelle qu'on
va aborder à votre avis il faut arrêter
cette désindexation du franc cfa et
laisser une autonomie financière au mode
et africaines qui leur permettrait
peut-être d'aller vers plus
d'indépendance
des c'est un débat d'abord une
dévaluation du cfa elle a eu lieu déjà
sous edouard balladur donc c'était une
première prise de distance parce que
tout simplement la france n'avait plus
les moyens de faire des fonds de fans
noire des pays africains ensuite on va
voir si un bon donner les les africains
en paieront le gaz en couple comme le
demandent les russes mais la réalité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on l'a vu notamment à travers macky sall
président du sénégal mais également
président en titre de l'union africaine
il n'y a pas eu de volonté de condamner
l'offensive russe l'opération militaire
spéciale des russes en ukraine s'est
déjà oui mais malgré diallo fracture
donc il l'a fait parce qu'ils étaient
aussi présentes de l'unité africaine
mais ça montre que les intérêts
économiques et des intérêts stratégiques
peuvent être intimement mêlés ce que je
crois aussi s'il faut éviter de
caricaturer les choses on a eu on a fait
en afrique des choses bien bonnes et
moins bonnes on est dans une phase de
redéploiement ça reste un enjeu de
sécurité nationale pour la france
l'africain la fois pour des raisons
migratoires et des raisons terroristes
même si certains disent que jamais
aucune opération terroriste n'a été
envisagée est planifiée du sahel c'est
quand même la raison pour laquelle nous
y sommes année sur le franc cfa antoine
glaser vous pensent que oui sur le front
16 francs cfa alors je voulais chavarot
gaitas de béotiens moi je constate que
en 2017 et en 2019 il a été proposé aux
deux zone franc
d'afrique de 1 de rapatrier la réserve
financière de mettre un terme aux
comptes opération quête à la banque de
france 2 de faire partir tous les
représentants français qui étaient à la
bcéao 3 de laisser librement ces pays
choisir une nouvelle monnaie qui est l
écho à l'époque quatre de dire ce qu'ils
veulent quitter cette zone peuvent la
quitter et donc ça c'était en 2017 c'est
une déclaration qui a été faite par le
président qui venait prendre c'est
prendre ses fonctions est ce qu'il ya eu
un mouvement qui a été lent relancer ou
lancée après ça moi j'en vois aucun est
ce que les africains sont d'accord pour
quitter le franc cfa ou une monnaie qui
seraient unis et ce qu'ils sont des sans
diviser là dessus donc donc donc le
français facile inverse celle d'un côté
vous avez des chefs d'état africains
absolument qui eux en particulier la
côte d'ivoire avec le président alassane
ouattara qui veut continuer comme
auparavant donc c'est plutôt les chefs
d'état d'afrique 1 qui freine mais ce
sont les sociétés civiles et un certain
nombre les opposants en général en plus
quand on parlait diaspora en france il
faut pas oublier que ce sont souvent des
ions qui sont des exilés politiques les
pro gbagbo en côte phares la côte
d'ivoire les pros lissouba pour le congo
contre denis sassou nguesso bref c'est
eux qui en fait à nîmes très souvent le
débat sur le franc cfa lui considère que
le français fasse c'est la monnaie c'est
la souveraineté et c'est une
souveraineté monétaire qui n'ont pas
mais ce sont les chefs d'état africains
qui freinent des quatre fers parce que
finalement la situation actuelle des
arrangements qs et pas simplement une
question de la france et sur la
francophonie marc antoine pérouse de
montclos est ce que c'est un outil
culturel pour faire rayonner la langue
française où c'est devenu un outil
d'influencé diplomatique c'est toujours
été un petit peu les deux donc oui c'est
un outil d'influencé en même temps faut
pas trop s'illusionner sur la réalité de
la francophonie dans l'ancien empire
colonial français en réalité il ya plein
de pays tchad niger où vous avez
peut-être 5 10% de locuteurs français
donc l'essentiel des langues parlées ce
n'est pas le français forcément dans les
pays considérés comme francophones ou en
fait l'usagé du français concerne une
petite minorité une élite donc
l'affluence culturelle de la france à
travers la langue dans les campagnes
reculées du sahel semble assez c'est
négligeable ce qui renvoie d'ailleurs à
d'autres questions aussi sur
effectivement pas le faut bien en parler
le recul de la france tant sur le plan
économique que culturel sur l'ensemble
de l'afrique avec une espèce d'ailleurs
de dichotomie qui m'a toujours frappé
c'est à dire que et c'est là où on voit
aussi les ambiguïtés de ce mot france
afrique parce qu'on pense tout de suite
à lancer en empire colonial mais en fait
l'intérêt l'essentiel nos intérêts
économiques au sud du sahara sont dans
des pays qui ne sont pas francophones ou
pas déclarés comme tels parce que même
les pays francophones ne sont pas si
francophones que ça en réalité donc en
réalité l'essentiel de nos activités
économiques avec le nigéria anglophones
l'afrique du sud anglophone les pays des
brics ou des min pour reprendre des
acronymes un peu à la mode et pas
l'afrique francophone donc il ya une
dichotomie parce que d'un côté
l'essentiel de nos intérêts économiques
sont dans une afrique non francophones
et l'un sur celle des intérêts
politiques en revanche sont effectives
dans les anciens territoires de lempire
de l' empire colonial et ça c'est
compliqué à gérer
[Musique]
alors didier castro va aborder les
questions de défense et sécurité
si ce n'est pas sous la pression des
terroristes pourquoi les forces
militaires de park and kill tel le mali
d'abord ce n'est évidemment pas sous la
pression
des terroristes ou d'une rébellion
interne et on n'est absolument pas dans
le dans le cadre ou dans un contexte
équivalent à ce qui s'est passé en
afghanistan c'est nous partons nous
avons décidé de partir et nous partons
de façon organisée pourquoi pourquoi
partant nous même si la coopération avec
entre les armées française et l'armée
malienne était bonne il reste encore
bonne pendant ce désengagement c'est
parce qu'on ne partage ni les buts de
guerre ni les modes d'action pour gagner
cette guerre et notamment il n'y a plus
d'accord politique entre le gouvernement
de bamako et notre propre gouvernement
il n'y a absolument plus de
correspondances entre notre et it
militaire et l'éthique militaire qui est
pratiqué par les femmes a soutenu par le
groupe wagner et ces deux raisons font
que
mais elles ont été prises de partir
général est ce que vous pensez pas que
il ya autre chose à savoir que wagner
par exemple fait ce que leur demande des
dirigeants autocrates en afrique mais
que la france avait sa propre vision de
la défense en afrique et qu'elle est
rejetée en quelque sorte
moi j'aurais simplement si on a trois
minutes à y consacrer refaire un peu
d'archéologie sur ce qui s'est passé au
mali ou si vous voulez bien mes cendres
est trop longue mais je vais faire ça
très rapidement en 2012 en 2012 il y
avait un cancer qui était en
prolifération extrêmement rapide le
groupe aqmi avait vu ses effectifs
multipliés par deux entre 2007 et 2012
ançardine avait vu ses effectifs gonfler
de 30 % en deux ans et zhao mourabitoun
allemand la thymine avait vu ses
effectifs grossir multiplié par dix en
un an par dix en un an et en face de ça
il y avait un état qui n'existait plus
qu'ils étaient limités à bamako et il y
avait une ariane qui était en déroute
c'est ça qu'on a interrompu donc est-ce
qu'on avait une mauvaise vision à ce
moment là je ne pense pas ensuite la
question c'est de savoir une fois qu'on
a atteint ses objectifs quels objectifs
militaires on peut confier aux forces
armées dans le cadre de cette crise est
probablement et probablement ça un peu
fatigué comme on dit en voile on n'a pas
dû trouver le bon vent tout de suite
c'est probablement ce qui a conduit à ça
est-ce qu'on a une vision différente je
pense que la vision absolument pas
changé la vision s'est donné les moyens
à ces pays de pouvoir lutter seul contre
ce type de
groupes terroristes donc la vision n'a
pas changé celle de wagner moi je ne je
ne prétends rien savoir de
documenter sur ce qui se passe au mali
je sais que les nations unies viennent
de sortir un rapport les accusant de
crimes de guerre crimes de guerre et je
sais qu'une ong qui s'appelle the
century a fait la même chose et on a
quand même une liste 200 exactions qui
ont été quand été pratiquée en
centrafrique qui témoignent qu on ne
peut pas avoir les mêmes objectifs de
guerre en tout cas même façon de le
faire que ces gens là donc je pense pas
que la vision notre vision a pas changé
je ne sais pas quelle est la vision de
wagner moi je pense que le wagner a
toujours le même mode de fonctionnement
c'est d'abord séduire en proposant des
choses que le droit interdit et que eux
seuls sont capables de faire ensuite
c'est finalement prendre le contrôle ou
en tout cas peser extrêmement fortement
sur la partie la plus haute de
l'exécutif le conseiller de ce tabou des
races étaient un russe de wagner ger la
troisième chose c'est s'enrichir la
troisième chose c'est s'enrichir en
pillant les pays en fait on est
confronté probablement à ce qui
ressemble un petit peu aux grandes
compagnies du moyen âge général vous
venez de déclarer à propos de la guerre
en ukraine que poutine ne pouvait raser
les villes en ukraine mais ne pouvait
pas les occuper vous diriez la même
chose pour ce qui se passe au mali que
wagner fait la même chose non avec la
complicité économique de la chine non
non non vous diriez pas ça donc je ne
vois pas grand chose à raser ou au mali
y'a pas le même rapport de force n'a pas
les mêmes il n'y a pas les mêmes
capacités qui sont déployés par wagner
wagner 6000 hommes c2c d'ailleurs quand
même une question qu'on doit se poser de
savoir comment ce gouvernement pense
qu'avec 1000 hommes
il va réussir à faire mieux en matière
de sécurité qu'avec les 35000 qui
étaient déployés je pense que ya pas de
comparaison entre l'action russe en
ukraine et l'action de cette
excroissance de l'état russe qui wagner
au mali bon donc pas de critique
militaire de la part de didier case quel
bilan politique vous faites vers
coudurier de ses neuf ans de présence au
mali qui s'achève par un départ quand
même
par ad pa ou 1/2 départ de la zone alors
là je parle sous le contrôle d'antoine
glaser mais finalement il ya toujours eu
5000 hommes dans la zone afrique de
l'ouest il n'était pas localisé au même
endroit il était dans des bases à port
bouet mais ses amis l'homme pour un
espace qui fait 10 fois la france tout à
fait mais on les a déployé dans le cadre
de l'opération barkan avec un point
d'appui quitté le tchad et puis là ce
qui s'est passé au mali est ce que la
france a vraiment été une surprise
puisque les français n'ont pas trouvé là
un prétexte pour se retirer
d'un pays dans lequel finalement bon il
ya des intérêts économiques il est
évident que les milices wagner et les
russes s'intéressent à l'or
et aux minerais mais nous on a peut-être
d'autres regardent et on va essayer de
se redéployer au niger on va être sans
doute un peu plus attentif sur ce qui se
passe en côte d'ivoire j'étais avec le
ministre des affaires étrangères le
drian en juin dernier qui est allé quand
même dire au président ouattara qu'il
fallait quand même se préoccuper de ce
qui se passait à la frontière nord et
être un peu plus vigilant et pas
simplement rester engluée dans le jeu
politique ivoirien
je suis pas certain que la france se
retire on a essayé d'attirer des
européens dans le cadre de l'opération
takouba on n'y a d'ailleurs ça a été de
laborieux mais on y est partiellement
arrivée au pire on a vu arriver ce qu'on
voulait pas voir venir c'est à dire
effectivement les russes et maintenant
on reproche au gouvernement de ne pas
avoir vu un email mais en réalité tout
change parce que rien ne change je ne
pense pas que la france quitte l'afrique
même si elle a adapté depuis longtemps
c'est mon répertoire en partant en
partant du mali antoine glaser est-ce
que c'est pas le signal que la france ne
pourra plus intervenir militairement
dans un conflit africain absolument mais
enfin encore une fois je suis pas
historien en plus mais je vais faire
l'historien il faut qu'on ce qui se
passe actuellement c'est pas du tout
l'histoire de la france simplement
l'histoire de la france en afrique c'est
d'abord j'ai toujours pensé que la
présence de l'armée française sert un
peu de cache misère à une présence
française globalement déshérence sur le
code sur le continent mais surtout il
faut comprendre que de la mauritanie
jusque plus loin que le soudan il n'ya
plus d'occidentaux dans toute cette zone
c'est une nouvelle période historique
s'il ya une sorte d islamisation jédir
chercheurs en parlera dix fois mieux que
moi il ya une sorte d'islamisation
radicale et serra au delà même des
djihadistes terrorisme et il ya des
changements profonds dans toute cette
zone il ya peu d'occidentaux le problème
de barkan dans le temps il vous aviez
des ong des coopérants dans les villes
il y avait du renseignement et cetera et
c'est ça m6 barkan s'est trouvé un bain
un moment donné un peu hors sol par
rapport aux réalités ses sentiments anti
français bien sûr instrumentalisé par
les russes mais il ya une réalité des
réalités locales de trafic de trafic en
tout genre au delà même des djihadistes
au delà même du terrorisme et donc les
russes autant d'ukraine c'est vrai
qu'ils détruisent tout en afrique c'est
vraiment à bas bruit et à bas prix ça
veut dire ils se payent ils vont faire
le mali c'est le grand pays de l'or la
russie ces grands pays de la bauxite est
en fait il ya une alliance chine russie
sur l'ensemble du continent africain ce
qui fait que les résolutions française
ona parce que le président le président
macron il a besoin pour sa diplomatie
d'influencé
vous avez un truc qui s'appelle le ccaf
un poste appellent au secrétariat
général adjoint aux opérations de
maintien de la paix que la france a
depuis 22 ans et que la chine guigne je
veux dire la france sont sont nos
rassasier sa sa diplomatie dans le monde
c'est quand même sept jusqu'à une
présence plus large et un blazer comment
on peut vous faire rayonner un peu de
sécurité dans ce cet espace si grand
avec quelques milliers d'hommes non mais
surtout il y un soldat sur 5 million de
kilomètres carrés c'est pas facile non
il y avait cent mille soldats américains
en afghanistan sur 600 mille kilomètres
carrés celle lancée par un d'ivoire
parce que si je n'étais pas comme ça
enfin je vais en général cassent ils ont
parlé dix fois mieux que moi mais je
veux dire c'est vrai que il ya eu un
moment donné ça a été poussé un petit
peu dans une certaine euphorie ceram et
ses volte c'était mission impossible
parce qu'encore une fois c'est pas le
problème de votre les finalistes le
problème des états c'est qu'eux aussi
ils s les trafics en tous genres se
faire dans toute la région on parle de
pays donc eu un puck les capitales il ya
plus de bamako il ya ouaga mais les
trois quarts des pays sont pas
simplement aux mains de jean dell
djihadisme terroriste c'est des trafics
en tous genres avec des jeunes dont
l'avenir c'est le conduire une bagnole
des djihadistes parce que en fait c'est
l'histoire antoine pérouse de montclos
il ya une idée fort intéressante qui est
mise là dans la discussion la
désoccidentalisation de l'offre est ce
que vous y croyez
est ce que la chine et la russie avec
d'autres complicités des milices et
cetera centaines de mètres dehors les
démocraties de l'afrique d'abord là le
débat il porte sur le sel à bout de
l'afrique oui mais où l'afrique
l'afrique australe c'est un épicentre
conflictuelle oui ou eurobonds si vous
aimez les conflits aller au soudan du
sud ou en ethiopie ou bien en république
démocratique du congo et vous aurez de
quoi vous mettre sous la dent de
nombreux conflits aussi donc on se
focalise parce qu'on est francophone
parce qu'on est français parce qu'on
avait l'opération barkan on se focalise
d'ailleurs sur un mot qu'on emploie
improprement qui est le mot sahel parce
qu'en fait le g5 c'est le groupe des 5 c
la partie occidentale et centrale du
sahel là aussi le soudan via l'erythrée
l'ethiopie qui sont également au sahel
donc on s'intéresse seulement une partie
donc je veux pas généraliser abusivement
à partir de ces de ces pays là mais je
voudrais revenir aussi quand même sur la
question du retrait de l'armée française
du malien pas forcément tous les pays du
g5 en sachant d'ailleurs qui a aussi des
exemples positifs dans la zone il ya des
exemples qui sont pas bons le burkina
faso où là aussi une junte militaire a
pris le pouvoir le tchad aussi où il ya
un coup d'état constitutionnel
le niger en revanche s'en sortent pas
mal pour l'instant et la mauritanie a
aussi une dynamique politique et
militaire assez positive il faut bien le
bien le dire maintenant le retrait de
l'armée française du mali donc du mali
uniquement il ya deux façons
d'interpréter je crois il ya une façon
négative qui dire qu'effectivement c'est
sous la pression des événements qu'on se
retire alors que nos soldats se font
caillasser qu'on s'est craché dessus
qu'on brûle des drapeaux devant les
ambassades etc et puis il ya une façon
positive gagnant mais finalement ça nous
permet de se sortir de ce guêpier de ce
d'éviter un ensablement encore plus
néfaste parce qu'on n'arrivait pas à
endiguer la menace terroriste qui était
quand même l'essentiel de notre mission
sur place et donc tirer prétexte aussi
de l'arrivée au pouvoir de junte
militaire pour finalement se désengager
avant que la casse ne soit trop trop
évidente et éviter justement le scénario
afghan où là effectivement les groupes
qualifié de djihadiste de terroristes
montrait davantage en puissance même si
aujourd'hui ces groupes djihadistes à
mon sens n'ont pas la capacité à la fois
politique et militaire de s'emparer du
pouvoir dans les capitales à ma
connaissance il ya un seul groupe en
afrique subsaharienne qui a eu la
capacité à gouverner une capitale c'est
les shebab en somalie avec l'union des
tribunaux islamiques mais ça n'a rien à
voir ils ont une vraie dimension globale
ya un appui d'un diaspora dans les
somaliens des états unis où norvège et
c'est là les groupes dont on parle
d'abord en termes démographiques vous
regardez un peu l'être démographie aussi
le nord du mali à quoi il ya un million
d'habitants c'est quand même un endroit
quasi désertique rien à voir non plus
avec la sphère de boko haram autour du
lac tchad où il ya beaucoup plus de
monde à le nigeria est le pays le plus
peuplé d'afrique donc on est quand même
dans des situations il faut éviter les
amalgames si vous voulez donc on parle
de situation où l'état recule ou est
quasiment plus présent dans des zones
rurales ce qui est tout à fait exact sur
la partie sur nous on pourrait dire sur
presque l'ensemble de la bande
sahélienne mais il convient de ne pas
généraliser du monde pour voir que
viendrait se substituer les chinois et
l'ensemble d'une essence généralisée je
voudrais faire une comparaison général
est ce qu'à votre avis ça se passe mieux
en afrique anglophone qu en afrique
francophone et au niveau des conflits
comme au niveau du développement
est ce qu'il y a à regarder ce qui se
passe du côté anglophone qu'est-ce qu'il
ya des leçons à tirer
pour reprendre ce que vous venez de dire
je pense que c'est important il faut
toujours essayer d'avoir une vision
globale
les conflits en afrique immobilise 70%
des casques bleus du monde il ya
soixante mille casques bleus des nations
unies qui sont engagés en afrique donc
ils sont pas tous au sahel donc ça veut
dire que quand même beaucoup
d'opérations ailleurs que dans la zone
francophone
quand on prend aussi les éléments qui
sont données sur les sites des nations
unies on observe que sur les surtout les
pays africains y en a 16 qui sont
considérés comme étant dans le cadre
d'un conflit persistant donc c'est pas
uniquement s'est pas uniquement la
partie francophone quand quant à la
comparaison avec les pays anglophones
d'abord parce que les français dont au
moins on n'a qu'une d'euros n'a qu'un
demi cerveau c'est à dire on regarde
surtout beaucoup la partie
francophone donc je vais pas capable de
faire des comparaisons je pense savoir
je pense savoir là où on a fait des
erreurs des erreurs en matière
stratégique parce que contrairement à
l'ensemble des commentateurs on n'est
pas tous des elfes du seigneur des
anneaux on n'est pas tous des êtres
parfaite on fait des fautes mais par
exemple et qu'elle fera moi je pense que
sur la crise malienne on a donné des
garanties de sécurité tellement forte à
bamako qu'on a interdit un dialogue de
négociations entre les gens du nord est
les gens du sud puisque les gens du sud
était sûr que la sécurité serait assurée
par la france et donc je pense que ça on
a en allant là mal mesuré et la deuxième
chose probablement il y avait au cours
de cette crise des bretelles de sortie
militaire de la france qui devait
permettre de remettre les acteurs les
uns en face des autres et qu'on n'a pas
emprunté il y en avait probablement une
après que on est cassé l'outil
terroristes qui étaient dans la rade ifo
race en avril avril mai 2013 il y en
avait probablement une deuxième
lorsqu'il y avait des élections qui ont
été reconnues par la communauté
internationale qui avait donné aux
maliens un président et qu'ils avaient
élu c'était aussi une façon de modifier
notre posture il y en a eu probablement
deux autres au moins j'ai pas toutes les
cités qui aurait aidé des bons trigger
pour ré articuler notre dispositif c'est
quand nous avons éliminé notre ben laden
c'est à dire droukdal et quand on a
éliminé notre al bagdadi c'est à dire
armés d'al tilemsi et je pense qu'on n'a
pas emprunté pour des raisons x ou y que
je ne connais pas et que je pas capable
de commenter le moment où on pouvait
remettre les maliens les uns en face des
autres pour qu'ils trouvent une solution
et ensuite comme c'est le cas pour le
coup de façon historique quand une force
étrangère reste trop longtemps elle
passe du statut de solution du problème
un problème du problème oui antoine
blazer ou pensées sur l'afrique depuis
de nombreuses années
finalement en deux trois mots pourquoi
ce conflit permanent à cause des
frontières
parce que j'ai du mal à comprendre
pourquoi moi qui ai tendance à
globaliser très franchement c'est des
problèmes de développement c'est des
problèmes de société qui n'ont rien à
voir les unes avec les autres enfin on
est quand même toujours en train
d'expliquer que ces 54 pays que
l'afrique du sud est c'est un
sous-continent ça n'a rien à voir avec
le reste je cite toujours l'exemple du
gabon où il n'y a pas un million
d'habitants grand maximum et vous avez
quand même le grand nigeria qui sera
dans quelques années ils comptent en
quelques années ça monsieur j'adore dire
ça je vais y aura plus de nigérians sur
terre que d'américains qui seront à 400
millions et autres donc versé on parle
de choses qui n'ont rien à voir les unes
avec les autres au niveau culturel au
niveau des hommes etc c'est vrai que
plus vous vous avancez - vous savez moi
vous connaissez sur l'afrique et moi ce
que je reproche à la france c'est de pas
qui est pas un type un jour qui a dit un
chef d'état qui a dit et si on apprenait
de l'afrique et si on s'intéressait
vraiment à l'afrique et si on essayait
de comprendre ce qu'est ce qui se passe
sur ce continent et vous faisiez vous
parliez tout à l'heure la différence
entre finalement les pays anglophones et
francophones
moi j'ai une idée c'est que les pays
anglophones eux ça donnait le pire le
pire c'est l'apartheid en afrique du sud
mais le meilleur c'est démerdez vous les
gars comme le ghana en parler en
dernière partie alors pour refermer en
quelque sorte ce volet conflictuelle
qu'est ce que vous pensez marc antoine
pérouse de montclos de la question
migratoire
on a un certain disent qu' il y aurait
une invasion d'africains en france dans
les décennies à venir d'autres disent
que les migrations se passe
essentiellement en afrique sans être
devin qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
les années à venir
au regard de la situation économique et
des conflits en afrique est-ce qu'on va
avoir de nombreux migrants africains en
france
d'abord la mesure des flux migratoires
est toujours compliqué ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est que l'essentiel des
flux migratoires
internationaux qui consiste à franchir
une frontière internationale en afrique
sont des flux inter africains et
notamment du sahel vers le sud vers la
côte atlantique des pays qui sont
beaucoup plus riche économiquement avec
beaucoup plus de potentiel comme la côte
d'ivoire où le nigeria qui sont
effectivement des grands réservoirs des
migrants donc sur la projection et
l'extrapolation vers la france en
particulier plutôt que d'autres pays
européens je serais bien incapable de
vous répondre franchement déjà on a
beaucoup de mal à mesurer la population
africaine donc sur les flux migratoires
alors oui il ya toujours cette donnée
démographique qui inquiète beaucoup de
gens notamment au niveau sahélien
puisque cela qu'on a des records
mondiaux de taux de fécondité avec
conjuguée avec une baisse de la
mortalité infantile fortes qui font qu
effectivement on a des populations qui
augmente à un rythme extrêmement rapide
un serment des records mondiaux donc ça
soulève beaucoup d'inquiétude mais en
même temps c'est pas les sahéliens qui
migrent vers l'europe c'est des gens qui
viennent au contraire des pays de la
côte atlantique nigérien les plus
peuplées ou bien la côte d'ivoire donc
il ya un peu un décalage entre cette
espèce d'épouvantail démographique mais
qui est pas forcément le propulseur on
sait qu'il ya plein d'autres et on peut
pas l'évoquer comme ça en deux minutes
il ya plein d'autres facteurs qui
peuvent pousser à la migration outre la
pauvreté ou la pression démographique
notamment le capital social des
relations qui font que l'on migrera plus
facilement si on a déjà de la famille
dans le pays d'accueil etc alors didier
castres à votre avis quelle est la place
des migrations monk avc était dirigé
plusieurs opérations dans les conflits
est-ce que l'émigration vient aggraver
ces conflits où elles viennent carrément
les déclencher est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous avez pu constater
je pense que nine les déclenche ni ne
les aggrave elle aggrave le malheur le
malheur des hommes c'est on a vu ça
notamment notamment en libye quand on
voyait qu'il y avait quasiment huit cent
mille personnes qui arrivent et
d'afrique subsaharienne qui étaient
maintenus en esclavage sur les zones de
départ de la libye et que chaque mois
chaque mois chaque mois ont capté en
comptabiliser le nombre de gens qui
s'étaient noyés en méditerranée je pense
qu'on n'a pas apporté une réponse qui
est pas du tout militaire on n'a pas
apporté une réponse collective du nord à
cette problématique là les italiens ont
fait quelque chose
les pays nordiques ont fait quelque
chose mais il ya rien de l'ampleur
nécessaire pour
lutter contre ce problème donc je pense
pas que ce soit c'est pas de nature
directement sécuritaire et je pense
comme ça a été dit que le premier pays
la première zone qui sera impacté par
ces migrations quand il y aura 2 5
milliards d'habitants en afrique ce qui
est pronostiqué pour les années 2050
c'est le golfe de guinée et c'est les
premiers qui vont subir le contrecoup de
ces migrations donc ensuite je sais moi
je n'ai pas de connaissances
particulières là dessus
simplement je me demande si yonne comme
on le fait pour la géant pour l'aviation
civile est ce qu'on est capable de
réguler tous les flux de tous les avions
du monde est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable
d'avoir une espèce d'agents s'il est
capable de réguler tous les flux
migratoires du monde en tout cas de les
ordonner alors hubert coudurier on va
clore ce chapitre conflictuelle par un
petit qu'un conflit particulier ce qu'on
peut appeler la malédiction libyenne on
sait que l'intervention française
en libye qui a consisté en l'élimination
du président kadhafi a vu en contrecoup
une diffusion du terrorisme en afrique
on considère que la position française
aussi dans ce domaine là récemment entre
les prises de positions entre les uns et
les autres est ce que finalement et il
revient à la france de prendre des
positions tranchées sur les pays
africains je voulais dit d'entrée de jeu
je suis pas pour l'auto-flagellation de
certaines élites françaises à l'égard de
l'action de la france sur le compte y
est ce qu on a plus le continent noir
d'un néanmois il ya quand même eu des
erreurs beaucoup plus grave que au mali
avec l'opération barca nous
effectivement le bilan n'est pas si
négatif que ce parent
il ya eu beau le génocide au rwanda
alors on va pas revenir là dessus
l'image de la françafrique ça quand même
été un déclencheur dans cette attaque
systématique de la de la françafrique et
puis il ya évidemment l'opération
libyenne où nicolas sarkozy et david
cameron ont réédité en plus petit ce que
les américains avaient commis en irak et
effectivement c'est un oui mais les
conséquences alors l'erreur de la
présidence acron c'est sans doute
d'avoir voulu d'abord être le centre du
règlement diplomatique de ce conflit en
organisant des conférences à paris qui
ne pouvait déboucher sur rien d'autant
plus qu'on s'était mis à dos les
italiens et qu'on avait commis l'erreur
de choisir le maréchal haftar contre le
président et est donc en avant at on
appris partie comme souvent on le fait
de façon un peu maladroite et fort peu
diplomatique et ça effectivement c'est
une erreur l'actuelle présidence qui au
liban ou ailleurs se commence par des
coups d'esbroufé et finit en général
dans une impasse merci
[Musique]
alors dernier volet de cette émission a
vu la citation de raymond aron
pourquoi restons nous en afrique si
l'avenir de la france n'est pas
concernée didier castres commencer par
moi oui agréable
pourquoi restons nous en afrique d'abord
d'abord pour ce qu'a évoqué antoine
glaser je pense que la france elle est
citoyenne de l'afrique et le premier il
devrait s'appeler team basé c'était un
sénégalais qui était qui était député de
la 1ère république et effectivement il
ya eu beaucoup beaucoup un certain
nombre de responsables
africains de notre ancienne colonie
autorités dans les gouvernements
français ça fait quand même un lien
qu'on ne peut pas couper comme ça ça
veut pas dire que l'on doit être trop
sentimentaux mais on doit pas le coupé
comme ça ensuite il ya quand même un
géopoliticien je crois que c'était
mackinder nduhayo soffer qui parle d'une
logique eurafrique i qui a un bloc aura
flic et un bloc américain et un bloc
asiatique et moi je crois aussi que les
14 km du détroit de gibraltar ne sépare
pas l'europe et l'afrique le réunissent
14 km c'est la distance qui entre le
bois de vincennes le parc de saint cloud
donc je pense qu on est liés par la
géographie et par l'histoire à ce
continent en tout cas une partie de ce
continent maintenant qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire ou qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
de façon évidemment très général moi je
pense qu'il ya quatre transition pour
lequel on doit aider les africains à
franchir cette étape d'abord il ya une
transition psychologique il faut quand
même qu'il regarde l'histoire comme elle
et pas uniquement histoire qui date de
la colonisation jusqu'à la fin de la
colonisation et qu'elle soit la libye à
tous ensuite il ya une transition
politique vous parliez des coups d'état
je crois que quand on les ressent cilss
en 37 tentatives ou coups d'état en
afrique depuis les indépendances deux
parents donc il faut trouver un système
qui soit plus stable la troisième la
troisième transition c'est une
transition économique je pense que
l'afrique ne s'en sortira pas en tout
cas celle qu'on connaît tant qu aura pas
une création de richesse et tuera pas de
pour on peut se promener dans les capi
dans les villes décapita quand on voit
cette jeunesse désoeuvrée elle n'a pas
d'autre solution ou en tout cas on lui
propose pas d'autre solution que de
rejoindre les sirènes des plus
alarmantes et puis la dernière
transition pour lequel il faudrait les
aider c'est une transition démographique
pour que la croissance démographique
arrive à être digérée par la croissance
économique ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement oui alors antoine glaser on
vient d'entendre didier castres défendre
un peu cette ce lien entre la france et
l'afrique mais sur la position de remo
arrow disant que l'avenir de la france
ne dépend pas de l'afrique nous sommes
ici nombreux à connaître un peu
l'afrique à l'apprécié beaucoup mais sur
l'a7 appréciation géopolitique qu'est ce
que vous en pensez je pense que d'abord
ma chute fut arrêté pour l'afrique aux
africains donc ça c'est une chose ceci
dit pour la france même le président
macron il fait aussi beaucoup de
l'europe et ceux qui a pas actuellement
beaucoup de l'ukraine et très
franchement pendant très longtemps quand
vous étiez allé à l'elysée quel que soit
le président des ses pairs ses pairs
dans le monde entier du lui parlaient
que d'une chose c'est de l'afrique qui a
qu'est ce qu'on vous ait fait fait dans
ce pays qu'est ce que fait encore une
fois ce poste sa diplomatie d'influencé
de la france aux nations unies c'est
l'afrique c'est parce que 70% des
opérations de maintien de la paix c'est
ce poste de secrétaire général adjoint
aux opérations de maintien de la paix
quand il s'agit de sortir gbagbo de son
bunker en côte d'ivoire c'est la france
qui lui fit qui fait signer la
résolution à l'ensemble de ses
partenaires et c'est donc la france de
toute façon la diplomatie une influence
de la france est sûr que la fake ceci
dit c'est aulas a freeze sisi vous
africain de se dit prudent de se définir
leurs relations avec la france il faut
changer africa france pendant longtemps
africain france étaient les chefs d'état
africains c'est pour ça j'avais fait les
réseaux africains les réseaux finalement
dans un premier temps la françafrique
c'était la france de la période mais
vraiment l'état français en suisse vous
avez l'africa france sont les chefs
d'état africains qui sont au pouvoir
depuis 30 40 ans qui utilisent condé
réseau privé ici on et dont on a inversé
le domaine il faut pas il faut pas
penser il faut pas voir l'afrique
les tipis l'afrique est totalement
mondialisé les mecs qui sont très
puissants pendant qu en train de parler
il ya quelques semaines vous avez le
président allemand frank steiner qui
était almayer john mayer pardon qui
était à dakar avec le président r 2
gagnent avec paul kagamé du rwanda et
avec macky sall le président sénégalais
en train d'inaugurer un stade de 50000
places la france n'existait plus au
sénégal adieu léopold sédar senghor donc
il faut pas et l'afrique est mondialisée
il faut que la france elles baissent
d'un ton et quelle s l'afrique aux
africains se débrouiller dans une
afrique mondialisée voilà ceci dit ceci
dit il ya 400 à 500 milles malien
actuellement en france alors qu'il ya
pas de nigériens mais non mais je veux
dire on est on est copains britannique
marc antoine pérouse de montclos
l'afrique aux africains vous êtes
chercheur l'afrique aux africains pour
que vous vous intéressez à l'afrique
pourquoi lierre des équins un important
centre de recherche et là dedans
autrement dit vous
mais laser viennent dire c'est parce que
ça accroît l'influencent de la france et
vous vous pensez que c'est pourquoi
finalement oui on peut comprendre lire d
où la coopération scientifique comme un
outil d'affluence ans assez souvent et
est compris comme ça effectivement mais
au delà singes audrey je reviens un peu
sur la question que telle que vous la
formule ye qui était pourquoi restons
nous en afrique et je crois que on peut
peut-être formuler la question ainsi
quels rôles pouvons nous encore joué en
afrique et c'est un peu différent et ce
qu'il en advient est très important
c'est à dire qu'on a vraiment une vision
je trouve un peu condescendant tout
l'idée c'est que la france manipulent
les africains va les instrumentaliser
pour faire voter des résolutions sa
faveur aux nations unies mais les
africains francophones savent aussi très
bien manipuler la france et les
présidents africains savent très bien
tirer sur les ficelles c'est pas un jeu
univoque ça se joue à deux cette
relation ne l'oublions pas est ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui très bien c'est qu'il
ya toute une panoplie un registre
d'action de la part de présidents
africains francophones pour utiliser ou
la france comme elle le vienne influence
aussi à l'international et la lutte
contre le terrorisme ça a été une ronde
formidable autrefois il tend à leurs
responsabilités autrefois du temps de la
guerre froide ont agité le fanion rouge
du communisme et puis alors on d'acheter
comme ça un soutien financier une
coopération militaire etc aujourd'hui
c'est le fanion verts de l'islam ou noir
de certaines courses aura deux groupes
djihadistes que les groupes djihadistes
vont invoquer que l'on va agiter pour
obtenir un soutien de la part de la
france et de la part de l'union
européenne pour justifier le maintien au
pouvoir de quelqu'un comme paul biya qui
est là depuis 1982 au cameroun en
imminent démocrates africains ou bien
idriss déby père qui était là au pouvoir
depuis 1990 sous sassou n'guesso j'en
passe et des meilleurs donc il ya aussi
ce double jeu voyez ce n'est pas
uniquement la france qui est une
politique d'influencé incompris gontard
de l'africain de l'afrique aux africains
regardons aussi la politique d'
influence des africains à la pompe on
aura alors on va conclure
on vint conclure hubert coudurier sur ce
sujet là la france a longtemps façonner
de la nature administrative et politique
des régimes africains dès lors du
désamour a commencé et même plus que du
désamour il ya plus que de l'humeur il
ya de l'hostilité et si on laissait aux
pays africains exercer leur souveraineté
économique politique culturel voire
stratégiques sans intervention de la
france qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais
c'est nous qui nourrit source d amour
parce que par nos propos juste à fait
d'accord avec mes interlocuteurs
gestione avec antoine pas mal de
capitales africaines nous avons
accompagné pas mal de président ensemble
et nous voyons bien qu'aujourd'hui comme
vous le dites les africains sont d'abord
nous connaissent souvent mieux que nous
ne les connaissons et ont des liens avec
le moyen-orient avec maintenant l'ordre
de l'est avec moscou qui font qu'ils
savent exactement où sont leurs intérêts
et ils savent exactement ce qu'ils
peuvent nous prendre ou pas il n'en
reste pas moins que l'afrique restera et
notamment l'afrique de l'ouest pour la
france un bassin de sécurité nationale
que dont nous ne pouvons pas nous
désintéresser sur le plan militaire et
sur le plan économique
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une grande
compétition il n'y a plus aucun monopole
n'y a plus aucun passe droit nous sommes
extrêmement surveillés sur le plan
judiciaire dès que nous faisons des
affaires avec ces pays là donc je pense
et je leur ai dit je le répète c'est son
l'autoflagellation jouons notre notre
jeu et notre prenons notre part dans la
compétition mondiale d'autant plus que
si les choses se réalisent avec la mise
en place d'une défense européenne on va
sans doute augmenter le budget de la
défense donc l'afrique reste aussi un
terrain de manoeuvres utile pour nos
armées quand c'est nécessaire et aux
endroits adéquats en somme didier
castres en nous sommes liés à l'afrique
l'afrique est liée à nous c'est un lien
sur lequel il faut persister travail et
persiste et persil séché pas ce que veut
dire persister dans l'année en tout cas
que sera présent de grandir ce lien moi
je pense que on a tout intérêt à
conserver à documenter à objectiver ce
lien simplement on ne considérant pas le
continent africain comme un sous
continent et
nous on nous considérons pas comme des
donneurs d'ordre je pense qu'il faut
avoir un dialogue qu'ils soient directs
avec ces gens là que la france considère
pas comme une ong et le continent
africain comme un sous continent merci
c'est là c'est les relations
diplomatiques a good day vous remercie
d'avoir contribué à cette émission très
instructive je voudrais présenter
quelques livres
alors antoine glaser et pascal airault
où venait de publier le piège africains
de maquereaux en gros c'est quoi ces
deux d'avoir perdurait dans les erreurs
non c'est plutôt de vouloir faire tirer
la d'oise magic sur le passé il faut
faut discuter qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant toute cette période et le
président macron est arrivé en disant
oublions le passé on est jeunes avant
sauf que ça fonctionne pas comme ça et
ça fonctionne comment ça fonctionne que
les jeunes africains ont envie de savoir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après les
indépendances c'est l'histoire combien
de jeunes africains savent ce qu'on
disait qu'il y avait des ministres comme
houphouët boigny le pôle famille
houphouët boigny était ministre santé
dans des gouvernements français des gens
qui croyaient à une vraie communauté de
destin entre la france et l'afrique faut
en parler de ça alors hubert coudurier
vous venez de publier un livre politique
valérie pécresse la guerrière alors
c'est un livre politique sur valérie
pécresse mais alors je voudrais vous
interroger par rapport à notre émission
sur le fait que dans ce livre il n'ya
pas une ligne consacrée à l'afrique et
dans la campagne électorale personne
n'évoque l'afrique ce qui veut dire que
l'afrique n'a pas de place dans un grand
débat politique comment vous l'expliquez
ce qu'elle a commis d'erreur elle a
annulé d'ailleurs ses déplacements qui
est des paluds à dakar parce qu'elle
voulait mailler le territoire aller
partout et finalement moi je lui
rappelais d'exemples de françois
mitterrand qui en 80 elle était partie
15 jours en chine et tout le monde se
demandait ce qu'il faisait et
s'interrogeaient sur sur sa démarche
la politique étrangère mon avis n'a pas
été suffisamment présente dans sa
campagne au delà des quelques erreurs
qui est la plus commune est dans un
contexte extrêmement difficile pour la
droite aujourd'hui et surtout d'une
d'une guerre en ukraine qui a permis au
chef de l'état d'être en surplomb mais
aujourd'hui on vive la mondialisation on
vit toutes les crises de la
mondialisation en même temps kessany
directeur politique et vous pouvez
constater que l'afrique n'a pas de place
dans le débat politique pour nos
élections présidentielles je propose
contre le débat de la primaire de la
droite a porté sur l'immigration et
l'émigration bad d'afrique alors ensuite
été un peu oublié mais je pense qu'au
contraire l'afrique à 2 a de beaux jours
dans les débats même si effectivement
c'est plutôt là la diplomatie à l'est
qui nous a occupés pour les dernières
semaines de la campagne un marc antoine
pérouse de montclos alors vous publiez
une guerre perdue l'afld la france au
sahel
ces pessimistes un peu alors c'est un
livre qui est sorti après sept ans de
réflexion en janvier 2020 donc après les
opérations servat les barkhanes et qui
faisait le constat qu effectivement
on avait confié une mission impossible à
l'armée française puisque sept ans après
le début de l'opération serval qui était
au début 2013 l'elysée faisait le
constat que la france ne pouvait pas se
substituer à des états défaillants et le
fond du problème c'est pas le djihadisme
c'est la crise des états au sahel c'est
ce que dit le livre ce que je disais
déjà début 2013 donc et aussi un peu une
réflexion dans ce livre sur la capacité
de l'elysée à ne pas surévaluer la
capacité d'action de la france bande
dinara que ce soit sur les faïences et
régalienne des et afrique et une
défaillance régaliennes évidemment mais
ça c'est un problème structurel dans la
zone donc ça pose beaucoup de questions
aussi sur nos capacités d'intervention
on peut pas se substituer le temps des
colonies c'est fini donc c'est pas nous
qui allons gérer ces pays voilà donc à
caen s'appuie sur des armes est
défaillante faut pas s'attendre
effectivement à ce que ça aille bien
loin donc ça pose aussi de gros
problèmes sur le type de coopération
militaire qu'on engage au sud du sahara
puisque les résultats ne sont pas
j'allais dire gentiment toujours au
rendez vous souvent ils sont pas
renversées alors didier de castres est
ce que vous avez un livre à nous
proposer un livre qui a marqué qui vous
a marqué dans votre réflexion m'a marqué
pour reprendre un peu ce qui a été dit
c'est que nous avons prolongé perdu
l'expertisé la compréhension des zones
dans lequel on intervient et donc depuis
le déclenchement de cette opération
j'essaie de combler uniquement
maintenant pour le plaisir
toute ma toute ma mon incompréhension de
ce qui s'est passé dans l'histoire et
donc il ya un auteur que je dévore parce
qu'il est facile à lire c'est amadou
hampate ba j'ai lu de ses livres d'abord
kaïdara qui est un recueil de contes peu
et qui est très très édifiant sur ce que
sont les peuls et puis sur la
colonisation avec ses bons et ses
mauvais côtés je pense que comme tout le
monde connaît ce livre adieu a dû lire
quand il était adolescent mais moi plus
tardivement cwi gouy mot commandant de
amadou hampate ba qui racontre la façon
dont il a vécu la colonisation dans la
région de bandiagara et en relisant ce
livre on apprend aussi beaucoup chaud
sur la situation actuelle merci didier
castres merci messieurs d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci à
l'équipe tels cp et je vous soumet cette
réflexion qui d'ailleurs a été
constamment en est qu'au cours de cette
émission c'est une réflexion de sékou
oumar
sylla économistes en guinée le mal
développement de l'afrique a un nom
c'est le manque de leadership politique
[Musique]